someone told me once life is just trying
not to be lonely it's like a bomb went
off inside my mind scattering all the
pieces every time I try to put the
pieces together something won't fit
there's something on the edges someone
like a dark shadow waiting for me this
face
that's everything that I ever did wrong
written all over it
you need to let me be what I'm meant to
be I'm not the one who dies I'm the one
who does the killing
[Music]
you
how did this happen me Oh feels the same
just like dark shadow just everybody
it's Charlie they just dropped a new
official teaser trailer for the punisher
confirmed the release date it is going
to be January 18th like we thought I
talked about that during my last teaser
video where like accidentally leaked by
one of Netflix's international accounts
then swiftly deleted so if you haven't
noticed the past week the Punisher
social media accounts have been spamming
a whole bunch of new content literally
right after they posted the teaser
trailer they added all those clips of
Billy Russo going full jigsaw that I
just added to this video at the
beginning they're still doing more
interviews they explain more about
what's going on during the season so we
got to break it down there's a new round
of that imax ticket giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Punisher moment
on the video I'll name a new winner at
the end of this so the big thing about
this footage is in revealing jigsaw for
the first time like his two personas you
have the Billy Russo walking around in
plain sight without his face covered up
with all the scars every mistake I ever
made is scarred on his face like he's
wearing his mistakes mostly talking
about the end of season one like which
is so graphic that I can't really add
that clip to this but you get the idea
if you didn't see they posted a 3d
poster of Frank Castle and some
additional like teaser clips of him
traveling across the United States like
there's a clip of him drinking coffee in
the diner there's a clip of his car
traveling that turns into the skull from
the Punisher logo there's just more of
where he's at at the beginning of the
season like I said during my last video
traveling across the United States just
getting to see the place that he's been
defending and all these wars that he's
fought in but never really taken the
time to check out the dialogue that he
has though makes it sound like it's
coming from inside one of his support
groups like they ended season 2 with him
in a support group and Billy Russo is
also going to be spending a lot of time
with the psychotherapist played by
someone who might be familiar to you if
you don't remember Floriana Lima
she was on the Supergirl TV show for a
couple years she's playing jigsaw
psychotherapist who's helping him put
the pieces
speak of his fractured mind back
together like the bomb went off in his
mind that he talks about during this
teaser at the beginning of this season
she just explained that even though she
has like some special storyline that's
going on during the season which she
couldn't reveal like some secret stuff
with her character she's genuinely
trying to help jigsaw at least she's on
his side when they start working
together but she doesn't know anything
about the shady stuff that he did or why
the Punisher tried to take him down at
the end of season one she does a lot of
work with veterans that are suffering
from PTSD so she just treats him like
any other veteran she doesn't know that
he's this super villain in the making
and I'm guessing that when he's meeting
with her at least at first or at the
beginning of the season he hasn't quite
created this special jigsaw looking mask
that maybe he winds up wearing later in
the season maybe this is like a
mid-season kind of thing usually that's
what happens with Netflix series is that
you build to like a really big WTF
moment in the middle of the season then
that carries you into whatever the big
final conflict is going to be which I
think it's kind of implied like I think
we all kind of understand that this is
building towards full comic book version
of The Punisher vs. full comic book
version of jigsaw albeit the Netflix's
interpretation of comic book jigsaw you
can kind of see that they dialed it back
a little bit to keep it a little more
authentic like they wanted to look
gruesome but it's more of like a Tyrian
Game of Thrones thing like if you
remember after a Blackwater during
season two Tyrion who's up to this point
called the IMP people make fun of him
for being deformed but during the Battle
of Blackwater he gets his entire nose
chopped off to the people around him
treat him like even more of a monster
but on the TV show what they did is
instead of chopping all of Peter
Dinklage's nose off with prosthetics or
with like some special effects they just
gave him a giant scar down the side of
his face this is jigsaw during Punisher
war zone played by Dominic West
obviously you know way more grindhouse
way more over the top they just did a
big interview about this movie for a big
anniversary like it's still one of the
big cult films technically of the MCU
because Kevin Feige helped cast arrays
Stevenson and some of these other
characters if you don't remember this
movie came out around the same time that
the first Iron Man movie came out so as
they were ramping up for that like
before they knew that Marvel Studios was
gonna be as successful as it was Kevin
Feige was also producing Punisher war
zone it sounds like when Punisher is
saying you need to let me be
who I'm supposed to be in like you see
the poster with the bag of all his gear
and the guns in the skull vest in this
hotel room is not really clear who he's
talking to if it's just his support
group or if he's talking to Dyna Madani
who's coming back from season one she
was the homeland security agent that had
a relationship with jigsaw then things
flipped by the end of the season she
helped him get his pardon helped him
take down Billy Rousseau they say that
when season two picks up she's actually
obsessed with jigsaw she spent every day
at his bedside but because he doesn't
remember everything they're in a really
weird place so she's still trying to get
him behind bars maybe they just have a
hard time prosecuting someone that they
don't have a lot of evidence against and
who doesn't remember everything so he
can't technically indict himself by
giving up information that might
incriminate him but for whatever reason
she's just having trouble taking him
down at the beginning of the season the
john pilgrim villain character or who
becomes a villain whenever in the first
half of the season was talking about his
character - he calls him a fairly quiet
person on the exterior a man who's a
Christian fundamentalist who's had a
sort of rage a violent side to him it's
buried deep then the actor who plays in
it just goes on to say I think where
this is all headed that sort of sight of
him is going to resurface a bit he says
it's not a cult thing for his character
it's nothing like that he's just a guy
who believes the word he knows that he's
got to follow the word by the word or it
would be too easy for him to go back to
his old ways if you're gonna change you
got to change they didn't make it clear
whether or not he used to be a member of
the military but it sounds like you know
just because of the themes of the
Punisher in the fact that Frank Castle
is in therapy in jigsaw is in therapy
that the pilgrim character is also
probably a vet dealing with his own
trauma in his own personal way through
religion or something like that they
don't say anything about why it is the
pilgrim becomes the villain of the
season and why Frank Castle has to take
him down but the way they talk about the
pilgrim character makes him sound like a
super dark twisted version of The
Punisher which is funny because you
remember the Punisher during daredevil
season 2 you're one bad day away from
being me you hit
get back up I hit him in they stay down
why are you doing this cuz I think
you're a half-measure
I think you're a man who can't finish
the job
I think you're a coward
where they were sort of positioning the
Punisher is the dark version of
daredevil so if that were possible you
have an even darker version of that now
it'll be a funny mirror for that moment
but let me know in the comments what you
guys are excited for during punisher
season two I know it seems like it's
gonna be the final season of The
Punisher and Jon Bernthal is fantastic I
hope that whatever they do with the
character in the future they do consider
continuing to use his character in
whatever movies they put Punisher in or
whatever other TV shows he appears on
but unless Disney comes out and says
something different there's still that
two year cooling-off period after they
cancel a show for that particular
character typically what happens is is
when they cancel the shows is that
Marvel will say don't worry this
character will be back we have plans for
him they won't say what those plans are
but then a little over a year down the
road what we'll probably hear is a
surprise surprise new punisher new
daredevil new Marvel Netflix character
projects popping up like they won't say
Netflix in the title they'll just say
these characters will be appearing in
these other vehicles be they movies or
the other Disney Plus streaming service
shows but it probably Disney Marvel's
interpretation of those characters it
won't be like the literal continuation
of these Netflix characters that's why a
lot of the actors that play these
characters like Finn Jones or Charlie
Cox feel like they're going to be recast
like they're done playing the character
because typically what you would do is
if you were gonna use the same actor it
would be more of a continuation of their
own series and it would be a
continuation of the tone of that but
they're not gonna do like the really
hardcore r-rated Netflix style Marvel
shows on the Disney Plus streaming
service just because from what Disney
has said about it it's gonna be firmly
pg-13 the only f-bomb we're using around
here it's Fred Savage like we've been
talking about the once upon a Deadpool
pg-13 cut of a Deadpool movie if you see
daredevil you see Luke Cage iron fist
Jessica Jones on the Disney Plus
streaming service it'll be a little bit
more like that I'll be posting more
Marvel soon leave all your requests in
the comments below though
congratulations Jesse Kumbha you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for that other
Punisher teaser trailer video and click
here for that
new Captain Marvel trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight